How do you start a conversation and make friends?
I'm Chad Littlefield.
I co-wrote a book called Ask Powerful Questions
Create Conversations That Matter.
And in this video, I'm going to share one
of my absolute favorite methods to make conversation
that can be used even in the most extreme
circumstances --an elevator.
Classically awkward scenario.
You can use it in many other scenarios.
But I want to share it in the context of using
an elevator.
Because if you can make conversation happen
in an elevator, you can make conversation
happen in a whole bunch of other context.
I will also share 2 traps that people often
fall into when they try to make conversation.
Let's get into it.
Alright.
I'm not a fan of fluff unless it's a sandwich.
So, let's dive right in.
The book is structured in this Ask Powerful
Questions pyramid with multiple different
skills and mindsets to be able to create conversations
that matter, I want to zoom right in on chapter
number 2 on this idea of rapport.
Which Will and I define as a creating a relationship
of trust with another human being.
And specifically, the tool that we share is
to follow your natural genuine curiosity based
on something that the other person is wearing,
carrying, or sharing.
So, that could be a lot of stuff.
So, imagine we're in an elevator, strangers
walked in...
Actually, we need a stranger.
So, imagine that you're just trapped in an
elevator with a stranger and all you have
to create conversation is what exists in that
little metal box.
Using this tool to follow your actual genuine
curiosity based on something that you see
that they're wearing, carrying, sharing, or
presenting.
And the reason this tool is so powerful is
that even though an elevator is usually silent,
right?
It's like a narrative that's classic awkward
elevator music playing.
Usually, an elevator is silent.
I would say that the conversation is already
5 paragraph deep when you walk in because
when this person walked out into the world
or they turned up in a zoom call, they knew
that they're going to be in public.
And so, they put things on their body to choose
to represent or say something in some way,
right?
And so, if you're in an all-gray sweatsuit
and you didn't do your hair, you're probably
saying, "I don't care right now", right?
And that's presenting something.
It creates an opportunity for you to be curious.
And most of the time...
Now, there's always risk when you're going
to start a conversation.
But most of the time, the risk here is fairly
low because they knew that they're going to
put this on.
I knew that I was going to have a wedding
ring when I was shooting today.
And so, if you're asking about my wedding
ring, what's the story behind my wedding ring,
I would have some really interesting things
to share with you.
And I told you something without even saying
a word.
And so, based on people's necklaces or clothes
or t-shirt that they're wearing, a hat.
But also, something that could be in their
surroundings all well.
So, what do you see in their space?
Is there something that you can reference
or ask about?
Ask to that person but it's in that shared
space.
So, there's a poster up on the wall and in
an elevator.
Being able to spark a conversation based on
a poster on a wall or something that shared
in space is much safer or more organic than
if you were to say...
You don't spark a conversation out of nowhere.
And say like, "Hey...
What do you think of the game last night?"
Right?
It's not in the elevator.
And so, when you bring it in, it has a much
higher potential chance of being awkward.
So, quick example or tip to help us work better
too.
If I were to ask my friend here a question
like "Why are you so 2-faced?", right?
You hear the amount of judgment in that question.
I would argue that there's...
It feels like there's a lot of judgment in
that question because it begins with the word
why.
So, a really great question tend to begin
with "how" or "what" and not "why".
I explain that in some other videos that you
can check out.
But a better question might be, "Hey, what
inspired the 2-tone paint job today?"
You see there's a little bit less judgment
and a little bit more genuine curiosity.
If you want to start really great conversations
and make friends, you want curiosity to be
high and judgment to be very low.
Now, before you jump off this video and you're
like, "Cool tool!
Let me go practice it."
Let me share 2 traps that people commonly
fall into when they try to use this idea to
build a relationship with trust and make conversation
with somebody new.
The first trap is that people go curiosity
shopping.
And so, they look around and say, "Ohh.."
And so, Steven who's filming right now.
"Steven, what a nice shirt.
That's so beautiful", right?
And when I do that...
That's cool.
But it's not going to start a conversation.
It's actually a conversation ender.
Because it's a sentence that ends with a period.
And so, you have to turn your shopping or
your compliments into a question or else,
there is no conversation to be had.
By the way, the idea is not to just to talk
about Steven's shirt or my friend's 2-tone
face forever.
The idea behind this tool is that when that
person answers that question even with a few
sentences, you're going to learn 3, 4, 5,
6 other things that you can be curious about.
Because conversation is very exponential,
right?
It's going to span out from there.
Trap number 2.
Big words.
Self-disclosure versus countertransference.
Oh, my goodness.
So, self-disclosure, first of all, a conversation
without self-disclosure is actually an interrogation.
Right?
So, if I'm sitting here question, question,
question, question, question, question, question,
question, that is not a great way to meet
someboy else.
And so, being mindful of using this tool to
follow your curiosity but also empathetic
enough to know when it's appropriate to share
and make a little bit of self-disclosure happen
between you and that person.
Countertransference is a psychological term.
I had a mentor who was a counseling psychologist.
His name is Jeff.
He's a beautiful human being and he wrote
a book about countertransference.
Countertransference is basically the idea
that when in a counseling relationship, that
when you are in a conversation and the councilor...
You say something that actually triggers the
councilor.
And they start projecting potentially their
emotions onto you.
And so, you want to be mindful.
If you get really excited about what somebody
shared because you have some commonality with
it, right?
If you find out that they're scuba divers,
your tendency is going to be to say, "Oh,
I'm a scuba diver too.
Can we be friends?"
And that's not the ideal to do.
The ideal thing to do is "Cool, that's a commonality.
That's really cool."
Keep that in the D-L for a little bit.
And just be curious about their favorite scuba
dive that they went on.
Be curious about some of their experiences
scuba diving.
And it some point, it'll make total sense
to reveal and self-disclose that you also
scuba dive and they'll be this beautiful connection
that happens.
If you like this video, I make them because
I believe that conversation should matter
in conversations that don't matter shouldn't
be had.
And so, Me and Will wrote a book all about
it.
Feel free to go on Amazon and check it out.
But I also believe information should be free.
So, paper does cost money.
But below, you can grab a free link to an
excerpt of the book to unpack in your own
time.
The free excerpt shares the first chapter
of the book which really lays the foundation
for this tool that I've just shared in this
video.
It was awesome hanging out in cyber space
with you.
Have an awesome day.